I’d rather have a science balloon
than a science satellite
With a balloon, there’s no need for rockets.
To get a satellite to hover over the same spot on earth
-- geostationary orbit-- you
you have to be 36 thousand km away --
too far to use some sensors, like radar
A balloon can sit a 1000 times closer --
in the stratosphere, 30 to 40 km above the earth,
and still be above 99% of the atmosphere,
with clear views of the stars,
or wide panoramas of Earth.
You can bring down a balloon,
tinker with on-board scientific equipment--
and then launch again.
Satellites, not so much.
Cost is also a factor.
NOAA’s four new geostationary weather satellites
are estimated to cost $11 billion.
Whereas a balloon flight
might cost just a few hundred thousand dollars.
NASA has been flying balloons for a long time,
but without any steering capabilities,
they drift in the wind across continents.
Now private industry
is getting in the balloon game,
with new technologies that are enabling balloons
to hover over one spot.
These balloons rise or fall in the stratosphere,
catching countervailing breezes that allow
them to stay roughly in the same place.
What can a balloon
with a scientific payload do?
It can look down at the Earth,
checking on storms or animal migrations.
It can look out into space--
peering at the surface of the sun
or collecting cosmic rays.
It can even do things in the stratosphere,
like study how ice crystals could reflect
sunlight and cool the planet.
How do you keep a balloon stable enough
to use a telescope?
Gyroscopes can help keep a platform
pointed at its target--
even as sits in a twisting gondola
But this isn’t an ad for scientific balloons
--
there are a few caveats
For example, while satellites last for years,
the longest balloon flights have been a few months.
And what goes up needs to come down --
so most balloons come with parachutes
that can bring their payloads down gently.